bella tutti ragazzi è benvenuta questo
video sono flavi gente ci siamo su un
gioco il nuovissimo che non ho mai fatto
di domenica che la presente si chiama si
chiamava come si chiamava a happy uil si
chiama è primis ragazzi prendete un
gioco dove ci sono delle cose strane
primi che succede che i personaggi team
muoiono in modo strano
proviamo io non so questi giochi nuovi
ogni volta non so bene come sono fatti
quindi vediamo come va e vediamo sempre
facciamo altri episodi insomma diamo
nati un'occhiata instruction press space
to start io cosa devo fare per myspace
ma c'è della violenza in questo gioco ed
è anche caduto in modo drammatico ma
quindi questo gioco muoiono le persone
ho appena ucciso mammana ma che cosa può
dio scena molto violento che strano che
facciamo dei giochi così violenti mio
dio non mi aspettavo proprio questa cosa
da happy with cazzo che mila di merda
ciao ragazzi e vabbè dai niente niente
niente proprio dalla tua mamma fa le
mine per ragazzi smetto di far finta di
non sapere che cosa però se mi è
piaciuta una volta di giocare è previsto
senza sapere che c'è applicato prevedere
la reazione sembra donna che volo ha
fatto
vabbè up altezza cagata veniamo dio sia
fini che è tanto è uno dei più strani
che abbia mai fatto ma ok arrivata la
parte difficile ma ci provo
l'importante è partecipare sì sì che
culo che come sai amico mio tutto
possibile bene ragazzi almeno il primo
andato così senza troppe figure di merda
il che è abbastanza strano minigames
special 2 facciamo questo con nonno ciak
che ne sa che è dio che cazzo sono
triangoli o bulgari illuminati cazzo
si sa che queste cose merda
ok ma domina romo che si fa
no vabbè la rega troppe cose pitt in
troppo poco tempo mai così non hanno fai
lo slalom tra le illuminati che tanto lo
sappiamo che ne sei capace a livello 3
macchine di tortura ma che è perché c'è
un piede in testa è questo ragazzi
significa che la gente non si deve mai
far mettere i piedi in testa perché le
battute ma c'è una classifica di battute
squallide non perché io vinco credo e
mezzo il prossimo anno mini game and
peace andiamo da questo perché solo
perché siamo ha potato faccio il suo
livello se non ho è di che cazzo è stato
mio dio ragazzi sei bellissimo ed i no
veramente è un figo
applausi applausi a chi ha fatto sto lì
potatoes è un genio e la madonna che
acrobazie no vabbè seriamente ha fatto
sta cosa
ogni 100 se ne escono coste perle di
livelli e fanta metri il simposio
d'animo su matrix che mi sembra no ma
comodo e non sei tra tanto mica ti
stanno arrivando lance nel culo cioè per
un tranquillo abbiamo gli riuscì a
faccia roba vabbè vabbè vabbè non
riuscivo mai a fine suo livello giallo
fenomeno che si è già fatta l'importante
e sopravvive ragazzi poi gli se ne fotte
wright five live no io voto 1 perché
sono trasmetto quello è un 2 ma non
importa spacebar xd cosa succede cos'è
sta roba da dal nome sembra una [ __ ]
chissà successo di io mi sono infilato
un ascia nel culo è infilata a sua volta
nel bene e ho vinto hubble a caso su
happy vista ragazzi succedono cose
ancora io lo lancia come ho fatto a
lanciarli alla spiegato era di te che mi
sono fatto male rega no vabbè patisca se
io tipo non lo prendo neanche lo kg ogni
tiro direttamente minchia che calcio in
faccia
no se questa è stata epica ragazzi è
stato bellissimo se non morisse sarebbe
ancora meglio però ok
ecco così si fondano i tavoli come i
veri signori con distruttivo bolton run
god 2 ma stai avendo del mal di pancia
si o no perché pedali in modo strano
fatelo dire ho vinto ben importante in
questo ragazzi poi chissenefrega del
livello va bene così detta altro assente
armeno sputato un qualcosa sulla mia
mano
non so se si vede non l'ho davvero mai
più cos'è hanno rifatto minecraft su
happy wings cementato che sguardo sexy
just renderman
[Musica]
ah bello lo zio ma lavori una spada di
diamante nel cesso guerri così tanto
questo mezzo sorriso da indagano che fa
veramente paura
il culo proprio c'è un po stronzo fino a
via in realtà è il padre di uk
travestito da anne der mensch mi stai
prendendo per il culo in realtà
vabbè ho apprezzato bello traversi
mentre lo voglio anch'io tra l'altro se
si può anche non execution per non far
questo di accusarmi che sostano come pio
che cazzo no vabbè ma sei serio ma
questa è tortura sexy tipo 50 sfumature
di nonno credo dai non fai vedere che
mister gray non è un cazzo di confronto
a te vai così godi [ __ ] godi fai
sentire dal gas lo fai sentire
eccolo questo no questo no anche quella
una posa sexy da e la cambiamo la
pecorino 2.0 fatale ziamika fosse andato
un po troppo nel trasgressivo basta
ragazzi sto diventando alquanto strano
rocket man andiamo su questo mi sembra
che ma comunque cosa ci fai anche delle
cose sconce fratello a parte così tipo
scopa di harry potter
ho lasciato la milza su quella merda
roba troppo brutta sì però un po più di
chi voglio vedere carico zio non hai la
cosa giusta
ecco quella è la posa giosa che imitano
la prossima volta che che faccia bella
che tra l'altro ci si trovi swing cosa
essa classe media posso posso scegliere
la difficoltà ma se davvero fatti ma io
lo voglio fare
arduo perché io sono hard cazzo sono
quasi visto lo stupendo di me stesso vai
vai vai vai no non lo voglio hard
perfetto sono in grado di fare queste
cose ma credetemi dio di quello da
eccoci ecco lo mandò scorso stavo
facendo
dai dai dai cazzo ce la posso fare mai
cali addominali ha dominato
lo so che ce li hai questo è un inchino
ma non me ne frega un cazzo degli
inchini no no non ci credo che [ __ ]
ho lasciato costiera no vabbè dai ma se
già stavo facendo se pensavo di aver
vinto quindi io ho esultato troppo
presto dai [ __ ] ladra sì sì no no
non ce la farò mai chi nella vita va
bene così va bene ragazzi usciamo prima
che mi venga in mente di farlo un'altra
volta di non riuscirci matthew crazy
ones facciamo cos'è stato don't move
grande bolla quale fa questa l'ho presa
waiting se con il figlio eva big pennes
ok a dall'aspetto spasmo man che è
successo o mio dio fa chi è a ragazzi
manco tectonic
[Musica]
flat 3 fulham ha fatto uscire alla fine
non lo guardano fare perché lo faccio lo
farò più avanti quando sono pronto per
queste cose belle
l'altro 1.0 da ragazzi un tentativo solo
solo per vincere giusto perché non c'è
gusto se non a fare se devo vincere
tranquillo proprio bravo no non ci
arrivo non ci arrivo più ma dai
veramente sì ma non ti devi in groppa re
il muro quella madonna ragazzi non
riuscendo a fare un boltro non ci posso
credere
la prima volta nella vita o mi chiami
amiche mi sembrava strano che non ci
riuscisse space to shoot devo sparare
annuncia ma che non è un volto è
cambiato è diventato un spara tutti
finché non si sa domizzi tipo e padre
gli ok bravo così bra eccolo lì il saldo
ma lo volevo lo volevo lo volevo
maledizione laramie nisco anch'io ecco
questo il mio modo di fare sesso
il tuo pene molto bello amico mi ha
fatto lo di è bravo così questa è la
posizione giusta guarda che bra la tua
moglie che è rimasta lives of in questo
livello mi fa abbastanza schifo io non
ve non è che vada avanti normale io mi
cappotto e normale ragazzi serve le sei
andando va a prenderla te lo prendi
anche le brioche dai ragazzi faccio un
paio di livelli medi giusto per capire
un attimino come funziona la cosa favino
io non so chi scrive le mio cazzo di
nickname questo un problema poi vj fa vj
fa vj ma secondo secondo voi questo
livello e per me a giudicare dalla
faccia dire di sì che a proviamoci un
attimo con l'elicottero che tatum l'uso
da avete presente quei livelli che a
farli solo vi entra nel cuore qualcosa
di qualcosa che vi rimane dentro per
tutta la vita ecco questo era al livello
del genere fa vince il percorso a wow
cosa vuol dire a wow che ha fatto
un'unica non sto livello a wow ciao fa
vj dai è sempre forte da iezzi primo a
fare con babbo cosa ho scelto perché ho
scelto babbo natale spiegate questa
scelta tattica facciamolo con steve che
ha bisogno ecco perché quel che può
meglio che scrivono fa vj ma a livello
in inglese
certo ma è ovvio non l'avete mica preso
da qualcun altro l'avete fatto voi sa
chi a cazzo proprio ok faligi shakerato
ma perché ma perché va a vado col padre
cos'è mi devi cercherà ma poi action
cocktail qualcosa oppure una roba ceca
del cazzo c'è che cazzo complimenti
bravo bravo bravo ragazzo in aula tutti
vi voglio vedere tutti applaudire per
questo livello meraviglio a tutti tutti
voi voglio senti voglio sentirmi se non
vi sto sentendo tutti sono gli applausi
veramente l'oscar amico mio l'oscar dove
ce l'hai l'oscar dovrei messo poi vj and
fa vj e i cloni nonno cia questa no
vabbè non puoi scrivere uno shock così
amico mio non te lo gioco il livello ti
prego vada arrivare alla fine ci
riuscirai fa vj and dye chiudiamo con
land perché mi sembra giusto dai padri
uk non mi deludere che poi non c'è un
nome era difficile veramente credimi non
so come ho fatto a farcela se ce l'ho
fatta io ce la potete farcela anche voi
ragazzi citazione del tizio che ha
scritto non sa che così il farcela
ovviamente era ironia per chi non
l'avesse capito ciak
che senso ha questo video ragazzi
concluso l'episodio è stato alquanto
strano questo episodio di è ma veramente
strano pro ok comunque ragazzi 6 video è
piaciuto la seta sotto momento mi piace
ai capace di facebook che come noi video
trovate la descrizione sono sempre siti
iscritti che ci rivediamo il prossimo
video ragazzi